look at a company like uber you know
they had to bend the rules to to be
successful
i think i feel feel fear quite strongly
um so it's not as though i just have the
absence of fear i've
i feel it quite strongly 40 of all jobs
they project in the next 10 years are
going to disappear because of technology
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
i believe a life hey it's evancar
michael and this channel was created to
help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the seven things
that poor people do
that rich people don't enjoy
okay let's kick it off with thing number
one poor people play by the rules with
jordan peterson
you know silicon valley tends to be
liberal everyone knows that and
the reason for that is that there's a
tremendous number of entrepreneurs there
and
entrepreneurs tend to be high in
openness and lower in conscientiousness
so they're creative
but they're also willing to break rules
you know which you kind of have to do
often hopefully not to a criminal extent
but you have to
well you know it's tricky when you're
trying to establish something new
because
look at a company like uber you know
they had to bend the rules to to be
successful and those companies that have
rented those scooters out and put them
on the streets everywhere you know they
just
kind of went ahead and did it it's not
something an orderly person would do
because they'd ask for permission
whereas the people who started these
scooter rental companies just said well
what'll happen if we put them everywhere
and the answer was that seemed to work
but
you know you have to have a
rule-breaking proclivity
in order to manage that thing number two
poor people
are fearful with elon musk you are
unusually
fearless and willing to go in the face
of other people telling you something is
crazy
and i know a lot of pretty crazy people
you still stand out uh where does that
come from or how do you think about
making a decision when everyone tells
you this is a crazy idea or where do you
get the internal strength to do that
well first of all i'd say i actually
think i i think i feel feel fear quite
strongly
so it's not as though i just have the
absence of fear i've i feel it quite
strongly
um but there are just times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear so
speaking of important things like people
shouldn't think i i i i
should people should think well i feel
fear about this and therefore i
shouldn't do it
um it's normal to be to feel fear like
you'd have to
definitely something mentally wrong if
you didn't feel fear
um so you just feel it and let the
importance of it
drive you to do it anyway yeah you know
actually something that can be helpful
is fatalism
uh to some degree um if you just if you
just accept the probabilities
um then that diminishes fear
so when starting spacex i thought the
odds of success were less than 10
percent
and i just accepted that actually
probably i would just lose
lose everything um but that maybe would
make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward
even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving it
forward
um so that would still do some good
um yeah same with tesla i thought the
odds of a car company succeeding were
extremely low thing number three poor
people don't learn from their mistakes
with jack ma
if you want to be successful learn from
the
other people's mistakes don't learn from
the successful stories
successful stories they make
don't listen to that there are a lot of
reasons behind it
just like um i remember the first time
harvard business school came to us
say jack we want to write a case study
for you
yes yes 2001 or 2000
they came they spent one week and they
write a report and i read
no i said this is not me and this is
this is you that's
no this is not us he said this is you so
the makeup is signed
and the case study go up and they start
to teach in a lot of universities
the next five years they invited me to
go to the case study
and they always find a competitor of my
company and
if after every case study alibaba would
die
that company will succeed all the
students agree
and actually every five years all the
competitors die we still survive
so how can you study this kind of a
successful story
learn from the mistakes the other people
no matter how smart you are
you will encount these mistakes
you learn from mistakes not because you
will be able to avoid mistakes
you were able to when these mistakes
come this suffer comes
you know how to deal with it
how to face it i
i the book i want to write if i
if i want if i can
it's alibaba 1001 mistakes
this is the most treasurable things
that in my life in my life is not how
much we achieved
it's how much we go through the tough
days
and mistakes also if you want to have
more self-belief and self-confidence
i've designed a special free program to
help you
get it where i send you a video every
day for
254 days the research says it can take
up to 254 days for you to build a new
habit and this program will help
you get it once again it's free and the
link to join is in the description below
if you're going to speak effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about when you want to do
something new
you have to you have to apply the the
physics approach
i remember nine years ago when i started
the alipay
people said jack don't touch the
financing sector because it's illegal
you may be in prison
thing number four poor people don't
adapt with tony robbins
i always tell people the most valuable
lesson i got from my mentor jim rohn
was i asked my father worked two jobs we
were always broke
we had no money for food and we lived in
a community we moved to which was i
thought they were all rich and we were
on the other side of the tracks it was a
lower middle class but compared to where
we lived before these people seem rich
compared to us
and i just didn't understand it and jim
said to me tony
it's not about the value of your soul
it's about the value of you in the
marketplace
and your father's skills are not that
valuable he used to take
he was an underground parking attendant
and he would take people's ticket and
make change
well the research now shows is being
done at yale's being done overseas in
england as well
and they found that 40 of all jobs they
project in the next 10 years are going
to disappear because of technology
it's going to be replaced by an
algorithm it's going to be changed you
know all these guys on wall street
you're seeing all these algorithms take
over and they're getting rid of all
these traders
right it's changing radically these in
these hedge funds there's three million
truck drivers
self-driving cars are here in the next
five years they will be the standard
certainly within seven or eight years
are you going to hire someone who can
only work eight hours a day
and sometimes gets drunk or can make a
mistake when you can
buy a machine right down the machine and
be in a position where it works 24 hours
a day driving
but no one is telling these drivers this
and it's they have to retool
now so technology is the biggest
challenge
labor is less valuable because of
efficiencies with technology and it's
going to get
better and better for technology which
is scary when you think about what's
going to happen for jobs
so i say to people you got to
participate in your own rescue
you've got to retool yourself the idea
that bernie sanders has of providing
free education sounds wonderful but the
education he wants to do is community
college
there are no skill sets in community
colleges today for the most part
that are going to prepare you for the
economy or a job that's there so what is
that going to do you're just going to
waste more money more time
we need to retool ourselves the
government's not going to do it for you
thing number five poor people don't read
with warren buffett
i should mention one thing about reading
it was at the library here at columbia
that i wish i spent
probably more time than any other uh
student
i i lived there practically but you know
i pulled the book out there
happened to be who's an american that
told me something about my professor
benjamin graham and then i looked up and
i went to the library and i said i want
to look learn more about this because i
learned this over here
that changed my whole life you know we
own geico now
because of that librarian directing me
to some other book and then following
through on that
it's the chance i i i read about
one-fifth the pace the bill does but i
still spend five or six hours a day
reading i mean it just
you can learn so much i particularly
love biography just
you know to be able to live the lives of
these people that have been
excited and seeing so extraordinary the
lessons and the
you know the discouragements they face
just everything about it so i did
you can't get enough of reading thing
number six poor people don't know how to
sell with robert kiyosaki
i always say the number one skill of an
entrepreneur's ability to sell or
communicate
number one because sales equals
income so if your sales are down your
income's down
but it's not just selling your customer
you got to sell your employees
that's really tough you know and then
next is selling my investors so i'm
selling
investors i'm selling employees
i'm selling customers and i'm selling
myself
you know i got to talk myself into i
don't have the day
i don't have the pleasure of being down
entrepreneurs have got to be up
because if you're down the employees
know it your customers know it the
market knows it
so number one is sales but when you look
at the big picture there's three things
an entrepreneur must learn
number one is pr and what you're talking
about is pr the other day fox news
interviewed me
to find out if i would endorse my friend
donald trump for president
you know how much that's worth you know
they they co-branded us
kiyosaki rich dad and trump
that that's incredibly priceless
you know so getting pr is the number one
skill
under that is marketing and marketing
does is like advertising
they want to set the customer up to get
ready to buy
oh yeah oh yeah i saw that key i had i
want to buy a kia i want to buy some
land you know i want to buy
this so the customer is now primed to
buy it that's marketing's job
then the last thing is a sale so if
you've done a really good job on pr
then you've done a great job on
marketing the sale is like that
you know they walk in they buy
but if you have no pr and you have no
marketing you have the pound
pound hard clothes well mr customer you
know what
you know in today's changing business
environment you know you should buy my
insurance you know
and people today hate sales pitches more
than ever before
so the number one sales job of a true
entrepreneur is develop your ability to
get pr
and i'll say it again most entrepreneurs
are not good at sales they're horrible
at marketing they have no idea what it
is
and they can't get any pr and so they
struggle
and again sales equals income so they
crash
and thing number seven the last one
before very special bonus clip
is poor people can't influence and
persuade
with jordan belford the biggest
misconception is that
persuasion is really for salesmen
that you like to be a closer because you
want to become a someone who makes money
selling stuff and and nothing could be
further from the truth
persuasion among all skills is the one
that
cuts through to every aspect
of your life and i don't care you know
you're a salesman trying to close a deal
you're an entrepreneur trying to sell
the vision
for the future that you have to your
sales force to your employees
to your customers you could be a
politician trying to sell your
constituency on voting for you
you could be a pastor or a priest or a
rabbi trying to
you know influence your congregation on
the value of believing in god and a
certain moral code
you could be a teacher trying to
influence your students a parent trying
to influence your children to make their
beds to do that
goes on and on and on so persuasion
is a skill that really without it
you know i have to say good luck trying
to really be successful in this world
it's certainly not the only thing that
you need to learn
but you could have almost everything
else in place
you could have the greatest idea you
could have the greatest
strategies for marketing things you can
have
the greatest work ethic you could have
your whole inner game set straight we
have a vision for your future the whole
nine yards but if you can't close the
deal
or if you're not uh speak to people in a
way where they'll want to buy into your
vision
and in a way that empowers them and
moves and take action then good luck
trying to get what you want in life so
what i want to really share with you
today it's a very short time we have
together
is this idea about ethical persuasion
ethical selling and ethical influence
and there's
a fundamental difference between ethical
persuasion
and what i was doing back in the day and
i'll tell you exactly what it is it has
very little to do with the system
the straight line system that's not what
it's about it's about what your intent
is
the biggest mistake that i made when i
invented the straight line system back
in 1988 is that
it was so powerful and so effective at
closing deals and
getting people to do things that you
wanted to do
but i didn't have the restraint to say
you know what you're only supposed to
use this
to get people to do things they should
be doing to buy things they
should be buying at the cornerstone of
ethical persuasion is this
fundamental core concept that i will not
persuade someone to do something that is
not
in their best interest and that has to
be like sort of
really the cornerstone of everything
that you do it's not about i'm going to
persuade this guy so i can make money
whether
he needs my product or not or i'm going
to persuade this guy to buy
eight of these items but he only needs
two because i can make more money
if he buys eight you get it so it's and
and it's crucial because
if you have that sort of gut check that
that i'm not gonna use this to get
people to do things they
should not do you're gonna end up on the
right side of things pretty much
all the time now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and how are you gonna
take action on it
this week when you schedule in what day
what time
and what place you're going to take
action you have a 91
chance of actually following through
versus just
a 35 chance if you just got motivated
but never created a specific plan and
when you share your plan publicly and
have some accountability you
increase your chances even further of
actually following through
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway and your plan of action this
week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
most people don't fail enough most
people are so afraid of a huge fail that
they don't
even try you're afraid of taking a big
bet you're afraid of going into deep
debt
and that fear prevents you from having
the thing that matters the most
right now in your business momentum
you don't need to fail big but you do
need to start
otherwise you will never build the big
business that you're capable of building
so i'm a big fan of going from idea to
action idea to action idea to action
idea to action get an idea what do you
do you take action
teach yourself train yourself as soon as
you get that idea
don't judge it don't think about it
don't plan and ponder and strategize
because your list of ideas is a mile
long and it's not going to get any
shorter
you're a genius you come up with great
ideas you're going to keep coming with
ideas for the rest of your life
that list of ideas is not going to
shrink
[Music]
so how do you start moving you take
action i call the two percent difference
instead of planning to get 100
for your idea what's the two percent
difference that you can just do
something about
right now i think your ideas came to you
for a reason i think it's inspired why
are you thinking about this thing
don't judge the reason just go off and
do something one small conversation one
small action
start building momentum that's the thing
that's missing right now is momentum
you need more momentum you're a genius
you have great ideas
you should be changing the world what's
missing is momentum and i want you to
find it
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below or if you want
to learn how to develop an insane
work ethic check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
[Music]
there